bonsoir nous sommes le jeudi 19
septembre bienvenue pour une nouvelle
édition du 7 8 l'actu sur tv fil 78
votre journal d'information locale voici
quelques-uns des titres qui seront
développés au cours de cette nouvelle
édition une député et un sénateur en
soutien à la candidate de l'ump à magny
les hameaux horreur bergère sur l'espace
de quelques jours la visite de valérie
pécresse et de gérard larcher à deux
anciens ministres le 21 septembre
journée mondiale de la maladie
d'alzheimer on estime à un million le
nombre de personnes atteintes ça
pourrait être deux fois plus dans une
dizaine d'années en france
je recevrai pour en parler sur ce
plateau la directrice du groupement
médico-social de géronde icap à magny
les hameaux
et puis la ville de la verrière se lance
dans la gastronomie à destination des
plus jeunes
en lançant un concours sur le modèle de
l'émission télévisée un dîner presque
parfait reportage derrière les fourneaux
à suivre tout à l'heure l'image du jour
ce sont ces sans papiers dans les rues
de versailles
ce matin ils étaient une cinquantaine de
franciliens de l'union syndicale des
sans papiers cela fait plus de dix jours
qu'ils ont débuté une marche de
protestation à travers le grand paris au
coeur de leur colère la circulaire de
manuel valls ministre de l'intérieur une
circulaire de novembre 2012 que les
sans-papiers juge trop restrictive et
non adaptés à leur situation
ils ont été reçus en mairie de
versailles avant de continuer leur
marche jusqu'au 6 octobre prochain des
élus et leur demander de les remonter au
plus haut qu'ils aient dû revoir comme
ils ont dit au cas par cas parce que
tous les cas sont différents mais tous
les cas ne sont pas mentionnés dans
dans la circulaire la campagne
municipale s'intensifient à magny les
hameaux en tout cas du côté de
l'opposition la candidate ump or berger
a reçu cette semaine le soutien sur le
terrain de valérie pécresse puis de
gérard larcher de figure de sa formation
politique
toutes les précisions avec ce reportage
la députée valérie pécresse lors du
forum des associations du ghana dernier
le sénateur gérard larcher lors d'une
réunion publique mercredi soir les
anciens ministres de droite se succèdent
à magny les hameaux pour soutenir la
candidature de rohr berger 26 ans dont
la mission confiée par ses aînés et de
prendre soucier risque une commune qui
détiennent depuis 1995
même si la chef de file de l'ump dans
les yvelines se défend de faire de cette
ville l'unique priorité aujourd'hui
toutes les villes sont des priorités
pour pour moi dans les yvelines
parce que je pense que nous avons fait
nos preuves de bonne gestion dans ce
département
les français veulent venir vivre dans
les yvelines la plupart des villes
même les villes qui sociologiquement
sont des villes très populaires sont
gérés souvent par des maires de droite
dans un département où majoritairement à
droite la communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines piloté par la
gauche fait figure de bastion et pour
gérard larcher maire de rambouillet
depuis 31 ans la situation va évoluer
dans un contexte de bouleversements
législatif
le texte qui est en cours de discussion
qui va venir le 2 octobre sénat l'art
bouleversé les intercommunalités et y
compris la communauté d'agglo ici est
donc face à ce texte qui est imposée à
marche forcée comment nous allons réagir
quelles perspectives d'organisation
territoriale c'est des sujets qui
intéressent les communes qui sont aussi
des sujets majeurs au précédent scrutin
municipal à magny les hameaux en 2008 la
liste de droite porté par jacques
rivaillé avait totalisé 36 % des
suffrages au premier et unique tour
arrivé sur la commune voici trois ans la
nouvelle chef de file de l'opposition se
dit satisfaite de son début de campagne
j'ai été investi par l'ump par l'udinese
si le rassemblement va bien au delà des
étiquettes politiques je vois là c'est
la rentrée donc forcément on accélère
encore la campagne en cette rentrée en
septembre dans les prochains mois
réunion publique porte apport proximité
rencontre avec les manoirs les
constructions du problème et dans ce
projet sécurité urbanisme et rythmes
scolaires devrait figurer en bonne place
optimiser les déplacements
professionnels limiter la pollution tel
est l'enjeu du plan de déplacement des
entreprises depuis 2008 le constructeur
automobile renault s'y est attelé sur
son site du technocentre à guyancourt
tour d'horizon des différentes mesures
en place avec claire combi depuis 2008
renault a mis en place un plan de
déplacement d'entreprise
en clair des mesures pour optimiser les
déplacements liés aux activités
professionnelles et limiter la pollution
en tant que défenseur de la voiture
électrique
le constructeur automobile a bien
entendu mise à disposition de ses
salariés des places mini de bornes
électriques
mais le principal levier reste les
transports en commun une gare routière a
été créé sur le site du technocentre et
des arts et desservent ces quinze
hectares actuellement bien en a
précisément mais cela bouge un dense il
ya six mois c'était pas la même chose et
peut-être dans un an ce sera différent
on a quatorze lignes de bus qui
desservent le technocentre renault
dans les nouveautés par exemple la ligne
91 06 dessert massy orly
des aménagements obtenu moyennant
finance auprès du stif et de
l'agglomération
résultat 14 % des salariés utilisent les
transports en commun concernant le
covoiturage des plateformes tests ont
été créés sans succès mais une
collaboration avec le site dédié aux
eyzies up est en réflexion
autre moyen de limiter les déplacements
en voiture le télétravail un accord à a
permis de se mettre un tel travail pas
un jour par semaine
là tout de suite on a augmenté de 30 35
% le nombre que les travailleurs du
travail à domicile et de fait moins de
déplacements seul point noir du
constructeur les modes doux comme le
vélo et la marche à pied ne connaissent
qu'un faible succès alors que 1500
collaborateurs habitent à moins de cinq
kilomètres du site économique aux
actions est un réseau d'entreprises mais
pas n'importe quel réseau il regroupe
des présidents d'associations
d'entreprises à ce qui représente 600
sociétés adhérentes des grands groupes
comme des pme également une fois par an
une réunion est organisée il y en a une
qui vient de se tenir à mène à montigny
le bretonneux par don catlin cela tôt
patrick jacques de dixmude étaient
présents donc on a osé docteur en
proposant de prison des coupures de 500
ou 600 une cerise à 6 ans
genre misikonyte sous sol
il joue autour d'une même table un quiz
sur les entreprises illinoise autour du
thème du bon goût une ambiance est
dépensé très sérieux eu son chef
d'entreprise et tous membres du réseau
proaction un réseau créé un 2008 par la
chambre de commerce pour mettre en
relation les présidents d'associations
d'entreprises coaction ce sont
aujourd'hui plus de 600 entreprises
adhérentes
c'est quand on a beau réseau et qui nous
permet à la chambre de commerce avoir
une relation privilégiée
un effet de levier un relais puisque les
associations sont pour nous un relais
vis-à-vis des entreprises c'est tout
type de deux tailles d'entreprises dont
tous les domaines donc l'industrie le
service
le commerce peut être un peu moins mais
surtout industrie et services est donc
ça permet d'avoir aussi des relations
entre pme tpe et grandes entreprises
et c'est quelque chose qu'il faut
développer sur notre territoire parmi
les associations partenaires le réseau
delta ski sur saint quentin en yvelines
un réseau puissant de 40 entreprises qui
totalisent 60 % des salariés du
territoire il est toujours important de
pouvoir travailler en réseau de
bénéficier de l'expérience des autres
d'échanger sur nos bonnes pratiques ça
permet d'être un acteur et d'avoir une
voix qui porte et pour l'ensemble de ces
entreprises au niveau de l'agglomération
de la région voire même deux
de l'état ça nous permet à nous de nous
faire entendre mais ça permet aussi aux
administrations aux politiques d'avoir
un seul interlocuteur pour toucher un
grand nombre de salariés un grand nombre
d'entreprises la cci des îles et ne
dispose également d'autres outils de
partenariat tels que le réseau plato là
ce sont des cadres de grandes
entreprises qui viennent apporter leur
expérience aux dirigeants de pme
invité de ce journal à présent à de
backlund bonsoir vous êtes la directrice
adjointe du groupement médico social
géré handicap j'ai mon handicap c'est
cette structure qui réunit plusieurs
dispositifs autour de la perte
d'autonomie et des situations de
handicap vous êtes venus ce soir puisque
le 21 septembre ce sera la 20e journée
mondiale dédiée à la maladie d'alzheimer
vous allez vous mobiliser on va en
parler auparavant quelle est la réalité
de cette maladie au tout début de cette
édition en titre je parlais d'un million
de cas environ en france c'est bien ça
aujourd'hui
oui on a recensé huit cent cinquante
mille personnes touchées par la maladie
ou par une maladie apparentée
l'association france alzheimer elle
estime qu'il ya effectivement un cas
toutes les deux minutes qui est avérée
alors après effectivement on parle
effectivement de 230 mille cas
diagnostiqués tous les ans alors osez
vous le mondial au niveau mondial
effectivement on a des chais beaucoup
plus important forcément 35 millions
aujourd'hui 66 millions d'ici 2030 donc
une progression qui est lié beaucoup
aussi à l'allongement de la vie et de la
santé sur les impressions de devait
chiffres et données entre autres et puis
par rapport aussi au diagnostic précoce
aussi qu'ils sont qui sont faits comment
se manifeste cette maladie quels sont
les symptômes aussi qui peuvent alerter
l'entourage
alors ce qui peut alerter tout d'abord
ce sont les plaintes musique c'est à
dire les trous de mémoire tout
simplement on a une perte de mots on a
oublié ses clés ça se répète on a un
doute il ne faut pas hésiter pour cela à
consulter d'abord son médecin traitant
qui peut orienter après vers des examens
complémentaires d imagerie scanner ou
irm et puis vers une consultation
mémoire qui est spécialisée ça peut être
également des troubles qu'ils sont
observés par le conjoint ou par un
proche
des troubles du comportement qui peuvent
être aussi un signe d' alerte les cas
les plus fréquents se sont vraiment les
trous de mémoire les diagnostics
précoces plus est détecté tôt mieux
c'est mais bio mieux pardon on peut
adapter aussi un accompagnement vraiment
adapté ce que je dirai aussi c'est que
la consultation mémoire il faut pas en
avoir peur
ça permet à la fois de poser vraiment
aussi un diagnostic c'est à dire on peut
là qu'est ce que c'est que la
consultation mémoire en fait c'est une
consultation qui va permettre avec ses
examens avec cette imagerie de pouvoir
passer plusieurs tests qui vont
permettre de tester
justement les différents types de
mémoire et de pouvoir soit écarté toute
suspicion d'alzheimer soit effectivement
de passer avec l'accord de la personne
des examens plus complets
ça se passe là en hôpital de jour et ça
permet effectivement de pouvoir poser
vraiment un diagnostic très précis sur
cette maladie que vous disiez ne pas
avoir peur elle fait peur cette maladie
parce qu'on ne peut pas il y avait un
peu faire peur et puis c'est vrai que la
première chose auquel on peut penser
quand on a des trous mémoire et ça
arrive à tout le monde c'est est-ce que
puisqu'on parle beaucoup d'alzheimer
surtout à lapproche effectivement de ces
deux journées mondiales
on peut effectivement craindre
d'être touchés soi même par cette
maladie or dans la plupart des cas
effectivement on écarte aussi parce que
les trous noirs ça arrive à quelque
chose voilà des très très très influent
avoir tout de suite mais qu' il faut pas
hésiter d'en parler d'abord à son
médecin traitant qui lui orientera après
vers les dispositifs appropriés
france alzheimer élaboré 15 propositions
qui vont être remis à la fin de la
semaine au ministère de la santé pour
contribuer à la réflexion du futur plan
dédié aux maladies neurodégénératives et
faire en sorte que le parcours de soins
ne soit plus je cite un parcours du
combattant
aujourd'hui c'est un parcours du
combattant pour obtenir des soins pour
être encadrée c'est très difficile alors
dans les yvelines on a des dispositifs
qui sont un très bon maillage de ces
dispositifs qui sont très présents
je parlerai de la filière psycho
gériatre et qui est porté par l'hôpital
de plaisir qui était assez exemplaire et
qui comprend effectivement tout un tas
de dispositifs qui permettent dès qu'il
ya suspicion d'accueillir les personnes
de pouvoir ensuite les orienter vers les
dispositifs adaptés
je parlais tout à l'heure effectivement
l'hôpital de jour qui va permettre de
pouvoir faire des examens complets
neuropsychiatriques de la personne et
puis d'orienter ensuite vers les
dispositifs qui convienne ça peut être
les deux accueils du jour aussi c'est ce
que vous proposez comment gérant des
caps intervient justement alors
l'hôpital de plaisir gère deux accueils
de jour y en a un qui est à plaisir et
puis comme vous le savez y en a
effectivement qui est au sein de gérant
des caps qui permet d'accueillir des
fleurs à magny les hameaux voilà j'ai un
handicap sur le domaine du maire en tête
qui permet d'accueillir les personnes
qui sont touchées par la maladie
deux à trois journée maximum par semaine
ça permet à la fois aux proches de
souffler un peu d'avoir du répit de
pouvoir organiser sa journée autrement
et puis d'apporter aussi un lieu de
socialisation aux personnes elles mêmes
et puis de travailler aussi sur certains
acquis travailler la mémoire notamment
est différent peut encore travailler la
mémoire même si lorsqu'on est atteint de
cette maladie d'alzheimer on peut
travailler la mémoire oui ça peut
s'entretenir
l'équipe pluridisciplinaire coordonné
par l'infirmière
organise régulièrement effectivement des
stimulations fait des jeux de simulation
ou en tout cas des activités de
stimulation de la mémoire le site du
maire en tête un très beau site qui
invite aussi à la promenade cette
promenade est faite quotidiennement
quand le temps le permet et permet de
jouer aussi sur les par exemple c'est un
exemple il y en a beaucoup d'autres sur
sur les repères spatio temporelle avec
les saisons qui change avec avec
l'environnement du coup un peu changeant
les couleurs qui change qui repère qui
sont très importants jean mondiale de
sensibilisation ce sera samedi mais
alors c'est celle ci dès vendredi voilà
ce sera dès vendredi donc la mer midi
d'information
voilà pour permettre au plus grand
nombre mais aux professionnels notamment
de venir chercher de l'information c'est
une après midi qui a été conçu avec
l'ensemble des partenaires constitutif
mais pas seulement de gironde icap une
thématique aussi enlevé la cité
l'accompagnement de la personne atteinte
de la maladie d'alzheimer et son
entourage c'est un balaran est très
important est effectivement en général
quand on parle de dispositifs qui sont
mis en place pour la personne c'est
aussi l'entourage bien sûr qui en est
bénéficiaire parce qu'on le sait bien
quand il nya maladie survient au sein
d'une famille s'est pas seulement la
personne qui est touché c'est tout son
entourage qui est impactée et les
conséquences peuvent effectivement
impliqués chaque membre de la famille
comment va se dérouler cette après midi
d'information pour ceux qui voudraient
venir vous voir ceux qui voudraient
alors nous accueillons les personnes qui
souhaitent chercher l'information à
partir de 13h30
et il y aura une succession de
présentation tout d'abord par les
professionnels de l'hôpital de plaisir
et de cette filière psycho gériatrique
autour du docteur mandelbaum bertrand
mandelbaum de cadre de santé qui sont
spécialisés qui expliqueront
effectivement en quoi consistent aussi
cette filière le docteur béatrice
stagiaires qui est neuropsychiatre et
puis les deux infirmière coordinatrice
des accueils de jour que j'ai cités tout
à l'heure il y aura également le réseau
car matt qui viendra expliquer comment
on accompagne domicile les personnes
atteintes de la maladie comment ce lien
est fait avec l'hôpital entre la ville
et l'hôpital autour de la personne et
son entourage
il aura également une présentation d'une
équipe spécialisée alzheimer qui va être
bientôt opérationnelle âgées handicapées
qui permet d'aller au domicile des
personnes touchées légèrement par la
maladie pour leur permettre de rester à
domicile en organisant avec elle et les
activités la vie quotidienne et puis
deux expériences intéressantes autour de
l'art et de l'équithérapie art-thérapie
alors l'équithérapie ça consiste à
utiliser le cheval comme médiateur entre
la personne et puis comme moyen de
communication
et puis son entourage ou les
professionnels il ya une expérience qui
qui sera développé on se laisse le temps
de construire le projet bien sûr mais
qui sera développée âgées handicap avec
les personnes qui sont accueillis au
sein des accueils de jour alors que ce
soit alzheimer ou l'autre accueil de
jour qui accueille aussi des personnes
en situation de handicap
et puis l'art thérapie consiste aussi à
permettre une expression artistique des
personnes et de pouvoir libérer aussi
des émotions ou devant tout cas de
exprimer quelque chose donc cette
journée mondiale ce sera samedi mais si
vous voulez des informations concernant
le site de magny les hameaux numérotées
rendez vous dès demain est un site
internet l'adresse qui s'est affichée
vous pouvez bien évidemment avoir tout
le programme détaillé juste pour
conclure j'aimerais qu'on s'attarde à
cet espace alors je vais sans doute même
le prononcer ce nom helen je ne serai
pas forcément le connaissez mieux en
tout cas c'est un espace de bien-être
sensorielle qui va être proposé mis en
place sur votre site ça consiste en quoi
cet espace et cette approche l'espace
nos élèves alors cet espace a été
aménagé et équipé en partie grâce à deux
dont du lion's-club ontinyent les trois
villages âgées handicap
et puis à des subventions recueilli par
j handicap pour aménager cet espace
alors ça vient du néerlandais comme vous
l'avez très bien prononcé sans voix les
stages de chevreuse de ce que cheuvreux
est proposé ce type d' espaces déjà on
envoie quelques acteurs donc vous nous
expliquer le très bien alors c'est un
espace de je dirais de kiel recréer une
ambiance et qui permettent de par la
stimulation des sens de pouvoir à la
fois avoir du plaisir simplement par la
stimulation de ces sens également de
trouver de l'apaisement
de calme et peut-être un état d'anxiété
en tout cas c'est un espace de
relaxation et une salle multisensorielle
voilà qui a été aménagé âgées handicap
au sens de l'accueil de jour des malades
d'alzheimer
voilà ce qui sera inaugurée demain alors
et on sera présent et vous aurez tous
les détails lors de nos prochaines
éditions voilà ça sera je dirais utilisé
par un professionnel formé à cette
pratique
nous y reviendrons je vous le disais au
cours de notre prochaine édition de
c'était sur cet espace nos allen qui
sera inaugurée demain et puis pour tout
les tous les renseignements les journées
la journée portes ouvertes ce sera
demain
l'ancien membre des effectivement à ce
que les personnes s'inscrivent pour
pouvoir les accueillir de façon
confortable
rendez vous donc dès à présent sur le
site internet merci à vous très bien
merci
une information concernant l'association
espoir à tchernobyl à présent basé à
saint quentin en yvelines elle oeuvre
pour apporter aide humanitaire et
médicale aux personnes contaminées suite
à la catastrophe nucléaire plusieurs
enfants vient d'ailleurs régulièrement
sur le territoire nous en avions
rencontré il ya quelques mois
cette association lance actuellement une
collecte de fonds pour financer
l'opération d'une petite fille
biélorusse paulina elle doit subir en
france plusieurs opérations de la face
l'hôpital necker annonce près de 25000
euros de dépenses nécessaires sans
compter les frais de transport et
d'hébergement
vous pouvez contacter cette association
qui oeuvre au quotidien pour offrir une
autre vie à ses enfants vous le voyez
lors d'un voyage justement là de loisirs
contacter cette association directement
sur son site internet ou numéro qui
s'est affiché à des ados derrière les
fourneaux le service jeunesse de la
mairie de la verrière organise
actuellement un concours a baptisé un
dîner presque parfait forcément vous
l'avez compris basé sur la populaire
rendez vous télé elle la première
sélection s'est déroulée hier dans la
salle du scarabée la deuxième aura lieu
mercredi prochain et il y aura une
grande finale le 27 septembre pour
respecter la tradition
yolaine thorez
mercereau 45 minutes montre en main pour
réaliser le meilleur dessert les
adolescents disposent de feuilles de
brick de poires et de chocolat une
recette que certains découvrent la
plupart du temps c'est plutôt kebab
pizza et grignotage une tendance que la
mairie de la verrière veut enrayer à
travers cette initiative
quand on leur posait la question mais
pourquoi vous manger ça souvent la
réponse est des questions de facilité
ces prêts en deux minutes on se casse
pas la tête c'est ce qu'on a dans le
frigo
alors que l'aah traverse ce petit projet
de lancement on veut leur montrer
qu'avec des aliments simples on pouvait
faire des choses en quelques minutes et
qu'en plus on pouvait aussi varier
l'alimentation les jeunes apprentis ont
tous entre 11 et 15 ans janis et mohamed
font équipe ensemble et sont plutôt
confiants comme j'aime bien la cuisine
j'aime bien cuisiner
j'ai pris cette occasion pour montrer
mon talent de débuter sur quoi ont
concentré la présentation et le goût et
la cuisson si c'est pas si ce n'est pas
trop difficile
présentation on a assuré on va mettre
chocolat fondu en règle on va mettre des
morceaux concassés sur le portant de la
suite
en cuisine on s'active le dessert prend
forme petit à petit puis vient l'heure
des dernières retouches les deux
animateurs note chaque assiette de
manière impartiale lui que pour moi pas
de emi sur les cinq équipes hier trois
ont gagné le ticket qui donne accès à la
grande finale le 27 septembre
pour les retardataires une deuxième
sélection est prévue mercredi prochain
l'occasion de tenter sa chance pour
rencontrer les professionnels qui
constitueront le jury de la grande
finale
moment et ces adolescents qui se
débrouille plutôt bien alors les
adolescents se mettent aux fourneaux
mais vous quel serait votre repas
parfait c'est notre question du jour vos
réponses au micro de patrick jacq d'edx
mais d un dîner presque parfait pour moi
on voit ça va être simple ça va être une
petite entrée foie gras ensuite un bon
une bonne viande avec des pommes de
terre
et puis un du fromage et une mousse au
chocolat en dessert poisson poisson
c'est très bien avec plutôt léger quand
même puis j'ai pas une salade une bonne
salade de fruits à la fin c'est super
beau un dîner presque parfait c'est un
dîner avec
des bons amis une bonne ambiance où on
rit ou soins dans l'assiette a de
l'importance mais au final c'est pas
c'est pas le plus important c'est trop
bonne compagnie voilà alors promis un
dîner presque parfait c'est surtout une
volonté se réunir ensemble de partager
quelque chose et de partager autre chose
qu'un repas et de vraiment d'une
certaine manière elle transcende être
bien ensemble communiquer échanger sans
respecter s'écouter et repartir de ce
dîner nourris de quelque chose qui qui
est autre que la nourriture terrestre
avant de passer en cuisine il faut bien
sûr aller faire ses courses et peut-être
irez-vous à vélo avec cette initiative
dans un supermarché de la verrière qui
va forcément vous séduire les clients
peuvent en effet y faire leurs courses
avec un chariot dernier cri on peut y
inclure des packs d'eau des packs de
lait une fois les courses terminées vous
raccrochez le panier sous la selle du
vélo vous ramener ensuite vos courses à
votre domicile service est gratuit avec
une caution tout de même on écoute c'est
la responsable de cette enseigne à la
verrière qui proposent ce service est
tout à fait le même principe sauf que
vous pouvez pas l'accrocher derrière un
vélo et en plus vous êtes limités en
poids avec un petit chariot celui là
vous pouvez mettre jusqu'à 30 kg il est
vraiment bien renforcé vous avez des
sacs isothermes ce que nous n'avez pas
non plus sur un sac cabas et classique à
roulettes
donc là vous avez deux sacs isothermes
qui permettent de transporter des
surgelés du frais très pratique jusqu'au
3 octobre se déroule le festival orphée
dans les yvelines un festival qui mêle
théâtre et handicap depuis dix ans cette
année comédie musicale et opéra en
langue des signes et font leur
apparition dans la programmation
aurélia de bissy pour ses 10 ans le
festival orphée réserve de belles
surprises
et à très denses sont à l'honneur mais
pas seulement l'édition 2013 est
l'occasion d'ouvrir la scène à de
nouveaux champs d'expressions telles que
la comédie musicale ou encore l'opéra en
langue des signes
première en france orphée oeuvre à la
promotion du handicap sous toutes ses
formes
et cette année donne un nouvel élan à
son projet ce rendez vous annuel
jusqu'ici présenté au théâtre montansier
à versailles s'élargit désormais à six
espaces en ile-de-france pour
l'ouverture frédéric zeitoun connu du
petit écran pour ses chroniques
musicales nous raconte son histoire
une création en avant première qui
traite avec humour et tendresse du
handicap bassin contient deux bougies
sur le gâteau et le fait d'être
nouvellement papa bon donner envie de
dire des choses peut-être de transmettre
le 6 j'ai peut-être un petit peu voix au
chapitre un petit peu une petite fenêtre
de tir pour pouvoir parler donc autant
bruit donc j'ai pas être ma vie avec
l'autodérision comme comme seul et
unique moteur c'est vrai vraiment on a
avec avec françois d'epenoux avec qui
j'ai écrit ce spectacle en fait on écrit
à quatre mains tout le tout le livret et
les chansons j'ai écrit tout seul par
les paroles et j'ai demandé de l'aide
certains amis compositeur qui
généreusement je pense à un service
d'amour notamment qui nous a fait cadeau
de deux de musique et dans ce spectacle
qui est donc un spectacle tout en partie
en gaieté en musique en en émotions
aussi qu' une des rares voire même sans
doute première fois au monde forme
utilisée pour raconter la réalité 2
de frédéric son tour une vie pas tout à
fait comme les autres que partagent ces
artistes professionnels en situation de
handicap
le festival orphée la plus à démontrer
que tout est possible
le handicap peut amener à une création
artistique différente car n'est ce pas
seul la différence qui compte lorsque
l'on parle de création le festival
orphée jusqu'au 3 octobre fin de ce
journal je vous retrouve demain vendredi
aux mêmes horaires pour un nouveau point
sur l'actualité locale et je vous
souhaite une excellente soirée
il